Jake: 好的
Jake: Okay.
Jake: 我们第一个镜头给到食堂
Jake: Our first shot is at the cafeteria.
Jake: 呵呵OK
Jake: Haha, okay.
Jake: 亮了对吧好的
Jake: It's lit, right? Okay.
Jake: 嗯
Jake: Hmm.
Jake: 对我们还有一场
Jake: Yes, we have one more scene.
Jake: 我们  呃  我我我每次还得干一个事情
Jake: We... uh... I, I, I have to do one more thing.
Jake: 就是
Jake: Which is...
Jake: 你可能也是随时注意着这些充电宝
Jake: You might need to always keep an eye on these power banks.
Jake: 得一直是亮着的上面的数字
Jake: The numbers on top need to stay lit.
Jake: 就一旦它关了
Jake: Once it turns off,
Jake: 我们就要再按一次
Jake: we need to press it again.
Jake: 就它说明它没有充上电
Jake: It means it's not charging.
Jake: OK  然后我们来set up一下
Jake: Okay, then let's set up.
Jake: 总共有这个iPad
Jake: We have this iPad.
Jake: 我给拿走
Jake: I'll take it away.
Jake: 5*5 我们几种啊 5*5 对
Jake: 5*5, how many do we have? 5*5, right.
Jake: hello
Jake: Hello.
Jake: 没有  不能帮忙
Jake: No, can't help.
Jake: 哈哈忘掉
Jake: Haha, forget it.
Jake: 帮我忘掉
Jake: Help me forget it.
Lucia: 他们到时会上来喝对吧
Lucia: They'll come up to drink, right?
Jake: 对
Jake: Yes.
Lucia: 舌头嘴上
Lucia: Tongue on the lips.
Lucia: 您晚上几点睡啊
Lucia: What time do you sleep at night?
Jake: 10  我们我们昨天11点半才结束
Jake: 10. We finished at 11:30 last night.
Lucia: 哦
Lucia: Oh.
Jake: 对
Jake: Yes.
Jake: 11点吧 11点结束
Jake: 11, we finished at 11.
Jake: 我们最后还要收拾这个
Jake: We had to clean up afterward.
Jake: 想一下这样
Jake: Think like this.
Jake: OK这样挺好
Jake: Okay, this is good.
Jake: OK OK OK  哎哎
Jake: Okay, okay, okay, hey hey.
Jake: 我标个笔省得它弄断
Jake: I'll mark the pen to avoid breaking it.
Jake: 你们眼镜可以直接开吧
Jake: You guys can start with the glasses directly.
Jake: 然后写个1120就行
Jake: Just write 1120.
Jake: 嗯
Jake: Hmm.
Jake: 1120
Jake: 1120.
Jake: 还有一个咖啡可以给他们选
Jake: There's another coffee option for them.
Jake: 子堂要不你来倒吧  我来洗
Jake: Zitang, how about you pour? I'll wash.
Jake: 嗯
Jake: Hmm
Jake: 我们有几个都没数
Jake: We haven't counted how many we have.
Jake: 如果有6个的话
Jake: If we have 6...
Jake: 好
Jake: Okay.
Jake: 是5种吗
Jake: Are there 5 kinds?
Jake: 6种  那再来一捧
Jake: 6 kinds, then add another handful.
Jake: 6个来排
Jake: Line up 6 of them.
Jake: 看看对几个吧
Jake: Let's see how many match.
Jake: 是吧Accuracy
Jake: Right, Accuracy.
Jake: 是这样的
Jake: Like this.
Jake: 这个
Jake: This.
Jake: 就就就是这样  好那你来倒吧
Jake: Just like this. Okay, you pour it.
Jake: 然后这个我们要想悄悄话了
Jake: Then we need to whisper.
Jake: 第几个是什么
Jake: Which number is it?
Jake: 第几个是
Jake: Which number...
Jake: 啊皇后多  对多跳一跳
Jake: Ah, the queen more. Yes, skip more.
Jake: 这这个顺序太  他拿第一个太像了
Jake: This order is too... His first one looks too similar.
Jake: 太低爆
Jake: Too low burst.
Jake: OK OK
Jake: OK, OK.
Jake: 我们先
Jake: We'll first...
Lucia: 说
Lucia: Say it.
Jake: 我们先到他吧
Jake: We'll first go to him.
Jake: 哎还谁最少啊
Jake: Hey, who has the least?
Jake: 他最少
Jake: He has the least.
Jake: 他最少那我们先到他
Jake: He has the least, so we'll go to him first.
Jake: 然后按照就是他能到多少
Jake: Then according to how much he can get.
Jake: 我们就别的就跟上多少
Jake: The rest will follow accordingly.
Jake: 嗯对对对好好
Jake: Yeah, yeah, okay, good.
Jake: 嗯嗯
Jake: Hmm.
Jake: 我来记一下
Jake: Let me write it down.
Jake: 我自己都记不得
Jake: I can't even remember myself.
Jake: 嗯嗯嗯
Jake: Hmm, hmm, hmm.
Jake: 好
Jake: Okay.
Jake: 不准往这边看
Jake: Don't look over here.
Jake: 好
Jake: Okay.
Lucia: 不打扰你的工作
Lucia: Not disturbing your work.
Jake: 好的好
Jake: Alright, good.
Lucia: 嗯
Lucia: Hmm.
Jake: 嗯
Jake: Hmm.
Jake: 来调一下这个东西
Jake: Let's adjust this thing.
Jake: 还得有帮手
Jake: We need some help.
Jake: 不然我这玩意
Jake: Otherwise, this thing...
Jake: 我我这玩意要重启
Jake: I need to restart this thing.
Jake: 一重启我就傻逼了
Jake: If I restart it, I'll be so screwed.
Jake: 给您倒茶
Jake: Let me pour you some tea.
Lucia: 这脆枣好甜呀
Lucia: These crispy dates are so sweet.
Jake: 我可能喝过
Jake: I might have tried it before.
Jake: 我喝过好几种了
Jake: I've tried several kinds.
Jake: 咖啡我也分不清
Jake: I can't even tell with coffee.
Jake: 这水估计更分不清
Jake: I probably can't tell with water either.
Jake: 倒完了
Jake: Finished pouring.
Jake: 好
Jake: Okay.
Jake: 为啥
Jake: Why?
Jake: 哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha.
Jake: OK OK
Jake: OK, OK.
Jake: 好我再拍一下
Jake: Alright, let me take another shot.
Jake: 来合影
Jake: Let's take a group photo.
Jake: 没法拿走
Jake: Can't take it away.
Jake: 就是倒掉它
Jake: Just pour it out.
Jake: 就是只给他留
Jake: Just leave it for him.
Jake: 瓶子 农夫山泉我们就用这个好了
Jake: The bottle, let's use this Nongfu Spring water.
Jake: 好
Jake: Okay.
Jake: 对对没拆封
Jake: Yes, yes, it's unopened.
Jake: 没拆封要不拿出来吧
Jake: If it's unopened, let's take it out.
Jake: 就是就咱
Jake: Just, we don't need to pour it out.
Jake: 就咱也不用倒了
Jake: Just this one.
Jake: 就这个
Jake: 不不不就是这个
Jake: No, no, just this one.
Jake: 当做样品
Jake: As a sample.
Jake: 对对
Jake: Yes, yes.
Jake: 对
Jake: Right.
Jake: 嗯然后这些装起来倒可以
Jake: Yeah, and then we can pack these up.
Jake: 咱还能环保一些
Jake: We can be a bit more eco-friendly.
Jake: 这个不倒
Jake: Don't pour this one.
Jake: 这就收起来了
Jake: Just pack this up.
Jake: 这个谁爱喝喝
Jake: Whoever likes it, drink it.
Jake: 这个东西这这段先别录
Jake: Don't record this part.
Jake: OK
Jake: OK.
Jake: 顺序不对的
Jake: The order is wrong.
Jake: 现在
Jake: Now...
Jake: 再再再乱一下
Jake: Shuffle it again.
Jake: 不一样的吗
Jake: Are they different?
Jake: 打个这对哎不
Jake: Hit this pair... oh no.
Jake: 然后这个收起来
Jake: Then put this away.
Jake: 把这个给  等一下
Jake: Give this... hold on.
Shure:  你提供英文代写吗
Shure: Do you offer English writing services?
Tasha: 我不提供英文代写
Tasha: I don't offer English writing services.
Shure:  那你就完蛋
Shure: Then you're in trouble.
Tasha: 干什么自己写吧
Tasha: Just write it yourself.
Shure:  我24交这周然后
Shure: I'm submitting it on the 24th, and...
Shure:  其实写的差不多了
Shure: It's almost done actually.
Jake: 写什么呀
Jake: What are you writing?
Tasha: 论文啊
Tasha: A paper.
Jake: 嗯
Jake: Hmm.
Shure:  我们饭今天已经点好了对吧
Shure: We've already ordered our food for today, right?
Tasha: 是的
Tasha: Yes.
Shure:  然后还差什么
Shure: So what else is missing?
Shure:  还有多久到
Shure: How long until it arrives?
Jake: 还有多久到
Jake: How long until it arrives?
Shure:  这么不靠谱吗他们
Shure: Are they really this unreliable?
Lucia: 喂
Lucia: Hello?
Tasha: 1133
Tasha: 1133.
Shure:  嗯行
Shure: Hmm, okay.
Tasha: 到门口了
Tasha: It's at the door.
Tasha: 用不用
Tasha: Do we need to...
Katrina:  昨天的这些旧的是不是可以删掉了
Katrina: Can we delete yesterday's old stuff?
Jake: 呀对对对对
Jake: Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Katrina:  那他一会别又
Katrina: So he won't...
Jake: 对眼线都删掉才可以
Jake: Yes, delete all the eyelines first.
Jake: 让一下
Jake: Make way.
Jake: 我要扫一下
Jake: I need to sweep.
Lucia: 嗯啊sorry
Lucia: Hmm, sorry.
Jake: 没有没有
Jake: No worries.
Lucia: 哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahaha.
Jake: 请坐
Jake: Have a seat.
Lucia: 谢谢
Lucia: Thanks.
Shure:  然后这样他们的时间码就对上了是吗
Shure: So with this, their timestamps will match, right?
Jake: 对
Jake: Right.
Shure:  可以啊
Shure: Alright.
Jake: okay一楼的就好了
Jake: Okay, the first floor is done.
Shure:  想想咱们烤肉今天要买什么
Shure: Think about what we need to buy for the barbecue today.
Jake: 你歇歇
Jake: Take a break.
Shure:  我可我可要把我祖传的手艺拿出来了
Shure: I'm going to show you my ancestral cooking skills.
Jake: 你可以在那什么美团里也买一点
Jake: You can also buy some from Meituan.
Shure:  我们
Shure: We...
Shure:  我们家传到我这边已经是第17代了
Shure: Our family has passed this down for 17 generations.
Shure:  楼上楼下
Shure: Upstairs and downstairs.
Jake: 放
Jake: Put it.
Jake: 先放楼下吧
Jake: Put it downstairs first.
Shure:  好
Shure: Okay.
Lucia: 妈呀这网好差呀
Lucia: Oh my, the internet is so bad.
Shure:  是的尤其你开完梯的时候
Shure: Yeah, especially after you finish using the ladder.
Shure:  上国内的就会很慢
Shure: It gets really slow when accessing domestic sites.
Jake: 我我得扫一下这个码
Jake: I need to scan this code.
Jake: 我我得把这个二楼的
Jake: I need to scan the GoPro codes on the second floor.
Jake: 这个一圈go Pro的码给扫一遍
Jake: I'll scan all of them.
Jake: 哎
Jake: Hey.
Jake: 十号
Jake: Number ten.
Jake: 从这边开始
Jake: Start from here.
Jake: 一号这是九号
Jake: Number one, this is number nine.
Jake:九号没关掉
Jake: Number nine hasn't been turned off.
Jake: 9号十号十号
Jake: Number nine, number ten, number ten.
Jake: 哎这不不要拿这个这个
Jake: Hey, don't take this one.
Jake: 他的腿断
Jake: Its leg is broken.
Jake: 这是个烂腿
Jake: This is a broken leg.
Jake: 10号 好的
Jake: Number ten, alright.
Jake: 谢谢
Jake: Thank you.
Jake: 11号
Jake: Number eleven.
Jake: 十二号
Jake: Number twelve.
Jake: 十三号
Jake: Number thirteen.
Jake: 十四号还在录
Jake: Number fourteen is still recording.
Jake: 14号
Jake: Number fourteen.
Jake: 15号
Jake: Number fifteen.
Jake: 子棠把他们叫上来了
Jake: Zitang, call them up.
Jake: 我还在点一点
Jake: I'm still counting.
Shure:  哎呦完了
Shure: Oh no.
Shure:  我刚喝完咖啡
Shure: I just finished my coffee.
Shure:  喝不出来
Shure: I can't taste it.
Katrina:  我也是
Katrina: Me too.
Shure:  一会漱一下口吧
Shure: Let's rinse our mouths later.
Lucia: 品尝饮料
Lucia: Tasting the drinks
Lucia: 饮料好像已经快被我们喝光了
Lucia: The drinks are almost gone
Lucia: 我记得
Lucia: I remember
Tasha: 还有存货
Tasha: There's still some left
Katrina:  天呐感觉有那个魔鬼料理
Katrina: Oh my god, it feels like devil's cuisine
Shure:  漱我口
Shure: Rinse my mouth
Alice: 那要把礼物拿上来吗
Alice: Should we bring the gifts up?
Jake: 呃 礼物一会再拿
Jake: Uh, let's get the gifts later
Jake: 喝完这个排完名之后再拿
Jake: After we finish drinking and ranking
Jake:对
Jake: Yeah
Lucia: 哦就是今天那种
Lucia: Oh, like today’s kind
Katrina:  我靠他居然能敷上去
Katrina: I can't believe he actually put it on
Katrina:  哇哈哈
Katrina: Hahaha
Tasha: 然后从每个杯子里尝出不同的水
Tasha: And then taste different waters from each cup
Jake: yes
Jake: Yes
Katrina:  yes
Katrina: Yes
Lucia: 不会吧
Lucia: No way
Shure:  怡宝我肯定一眼能尝出来
Shure: I can recognize Yibao water instantly
Jake: 为什么呢
Jake: Why?
Shure:  因为怡宝和农夫山泉这两个我都能尝出来
Shure: Because I can recognize both Yibao and Nongfu Spring
Shure:  真的这咖啡
Shure: Seriously, this coffee
Shure:  早说这个活动不喝咖啡
Shure: Should’ve said no coffee for this event
Shure:  先擦擦舌头
Shure: Let's wipe our tongues first
Katrina:  擦擦舌头
Katrina: Wipe our tongues
Jake: 擦一擦
Jake: Wipe it
Alice: 这是什么
Alice: What's this?
Alice: 这是
Alice: This is
Alice: 苏打水跟什么
Alice: Soda water with what?
Shure:  水水水水水水水
Shure: Water, water, water, water, water, water
Alice: 这个不是有气泡吗
Alice: Isn't this carbonated?
Shure:  啊只有一杯是那个元气森林
Shure: Ah, only one cup is the Yuanqi Forest
Shure:  其他都是普通的
Shure: The rest are regular
Alice: 这是要干嘛
Alice: What's the plan?
Lucia: 这是
Lucia: This is
Shure:  品鉴
Shure: Tasting
Lucia: 品鉴不同的水
Lucia: Tasting different waters
Jake: 好请大家请坐
Jake: Alright, everyone, please sit
Jake: 各就各位
Jake: Take your positions
Jake: 齐了吗没齐
Jake: Are we all here? No?
Jake: 大家挑一个位置吧
Jake: Everyone, pick a spot
Jake: 座位也不太重要
Jake: The seating isn't that important.
Jake: 薇薇干嘛去了
Jake: Where did Tasha go?
Shure:  薇薇有点急事
Shure: Tasha had something urgent.
Jake: 哦莫急莫急
Jake: Oh, don't worry, don't worry.
Alice: 这个这个
Alice: This one, this one.
Alice: 放这吧放那边吧
Alice: Put it here or put it there.
Tasha: 你要不坐那啊
Violet: Why don't you sit there?
Shure:  你坐那没有想Siri
Shure: Sitting there doesn't remind you of Siri.
Shure:  尝试一下king
Shure: Try king.
Alice: 哪个要喝了吗
Alice: Is anyone going to drink it?
Jake: 等等一下吧
Jake: Wait a minute.
Jake: 就是薇薇她是出不来是吧
Jake: So, Tasha can't come out, right?
Alice: 呃几分钟就好了
Alice: Uh, just a few minutes.
Jake: 好那等等她吧
Jake: Okay, let's wait for her.
Alice: 你不会要喝哪哪个的味道吧
Alice: You're not going to drink that flavor, are you?
Shure:  是的yes
Shure: Yes, I am.
Shure:  你觉得你能尝出来吗
Shure: Do you think you can taste the difference?
Katrina:  我从来没有留意过
Katrina: I've never really paid attention.
Katrina:  就是不同矿泉水的味道
Katrina: To the different tastes of mineral water.
Shure:  你不会就忠于买哪个牌子吗
Shure: Don't you stick to one brand?
Katrina:  不会啊随便买
Katrina: No, I just buy any.
Katrina:  不是哪个价格低就买哪个
Katrina: I usually buy the cheapest one.
Shure:  我就不爱喝农夫山泉
Shure: I just don't like Nongfu Spring.
Shure:  其他都可以
Shure: Any other brand is fine.
Shure:  所以农夫山泉一定能尝
Shure: So, I can definitely taste Nongfu Spring.
Shure:  然后最爱喝的是怡宝啊
Shure: And my favorite is Yibao.
Alice: 对怡宝甜
Alice: Yeah, Yibao is sweet.
Shure:  对怡宝是甜
Shure: Yeah, Yibao is sweet.
Shure:  农夫山泉根本不甜
Shure: Nongfu Spring isn't sweet at all.
Shure:  好像怡宝是偏一点酸性
Shure: It seems like Yibao is slightly acidic.
Shure:  说是不是那么健康
Shure: They say it's not that healthy.
Katrina:  哪个
Katrina: Which one?
Shure:  怡宝  就是它PH值
Shure: Yibao, because of its pH level.
Katrina:  哪个水最好来着
Katrina: Which water is the best?
Shure:  娃哈哈哦
Shure: Wahaha.
Alice: 娃哈哈最啥实
Alice: Wahaha is the most reliable.
Shure:  实验用水都是
Shure: It's used for experiments.
Jake: 好
Jake: Okay.
Jake: 好这个
Jake: Alright, this one.
Jake: 怎么说呢
Jake: How should I put it?
Jake: 先不要说话
Jake: Don't talk yet.
Jake: 然后写答案
Jake: Then write your answers.
Jake: 好可以开始
Jake: Okay, you can start.
Jake: 不要交流
Jake: No talking.
Jake: 对  不要
Jake: Yes, no talking.
Jake: 写写写充电宝上
Jake: Write it, write it on the power bank.
Jake: 来发充电宝
Jake: Here, pass out the power banks.
Shure:  我的充电宝真的都当手卡用
Shure: I really use my power bank as a hand card.
Tasha: 只有一根笔吧
Tasha: There's only one pen, right?
Jake: 对一支笔
Jake: Yes, only one pen.
Jake: 或者哈哈
Jake: Or, haha...
Jake: 嗯
Jake: Hmm...
Lucia: 我记得楼下有便签啊哎
Lucia: I remember there are sticky notes downstairs, hey.
Jake: 对用便签也可以
Jake: Yeah, using sticky notes is fine too.
Jake: 但是笔就这么一点
Jake: But there's only a little bit of pen.
Jake: 我有笔我有笔
Jake: I have a pen, I have a pen.
Alice: 现在是不是可以开始尝了
Alice: Can we start tasting now?
Alice: 吧
Alice: Right?
Jake: 什么什么
Jake: What, what?
Alice: 可以开始喝了吧
Alice: Can we start drinking now?
Jake: 可以上了
Jake: You can start now.
Katrina:  一直连不上啊
Katrina: It just won't connect.
Shure:  没开机吧
Shure: Maybe it's not turned on.
Jake: 确实
Jake: Indeed.
Jake: 很有可能
Jake: Very possible.
Jake: 哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha.
Shure:  你别别这么夸
Shure: Don't praise me like that.
Shure:  哈哈哈我没法接了哈哈哈
Shure: Hahaha, I can't respond to that, hahaha.
Lucia: 应该说不愧是我
Lucia: You should say, "As expected of me."
Shure:  这怎么还甜呢
Shure: Why is this sweet?
Shure:  不是他哎呀
Shure: Not him, oh gosh.
Jake: 不准说话啊
Jake: No talking.
Jake: 可以就是把握尺度啊
Jake: You can, just keep it within limits.
Jake: 就是保证你们答案不一样
Jake: Just make sure your answers are different.
Shure:  嗯这个尝试
Shure: Hmm, this attempt...
Alice: 好像咖啡喝啥都一个味
Alice: Everything tastes like coffee, doesn't it?
Lucia: 完了
Lucia: Oh no.
Shure:  有这个应该提前通知我们一下
Shure: You should have notified us about this in advance.
Jake: 咖啡还是得喝的
Jake: You still have to drink the coffee.
Jake: 对吧好
Jake: Right, okay.
Tasha: 这瓶是矿泉水
Tasha: This bottle is mineral water.
Jake: 这应该是食堂里
Jake: This should be from the cafeteria.
Jake: 哦你找到了一些
Jake: Oh, you found some.
Lucia: 好多矿泉水
Lucia: Lots of mineral water.
Jake: 哈哈好搞笑
Jake: Haha, so funny.
Tasha: 这个是矿泉水
Tasha: This is mineral water.
Lucia: 哈哈
Lucia: Haha.
Jake: 哈哈矿泉水
Jake: Haha, mineral water.
Jake: 对是谢彬竹带来的
Jake: Yes, it's from Xie Bin Zhu.
Tasha: 你不用喝都知道
Tasha: You don't even need to taste it to know.
Jake: 好酷这个
Jake: This is so cool.
Jake: 我我们找到一些环保的方案哈哈哈
Jake: We found some eco-friendly solutions, haha.
Lucia: 废物利用
Lucia: Waste utilization.
Jake: 太环保了
Jake: So eco-friendly.
Tasha: 这个餐巾纸我想要一张
Tasha: I want one of these napkins.
Tasha: 这倒的漏出来了水好不好意思
Tasha: Oh no, I spilled some water, sorry.
Jake: 不差了不差了
Jake: It's okay, it's okay.
Jake: 然后这边有好几支笔
Jake: And here we have several pens.
Lucia: 我是不是得用这种啊
Lucia: Should I use this one?
Lucia: 你也是可以
Lucia: You can too.
Jake: 你们就换着用
Jake: You can just switch them.
Jake: 或者有没有纸
Jake: Or do we have paper?
Lucia: 这样我就可以用
Lucia: Then I can use it.
Tasha: 这这个是怎么怎么呢
Tasha: How do we do this?
Tasha: 怎么写编号呢
Tasha: How do we write the numbers?
Tasha: 哦哦123456
Tasha: Oh, oh, 1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6.
Jake: 对哦嗯
Jake: Yes, exactly.
Jake: 我我我我我觉得这个有点小
Jake: I think this is a bit small.
Lucia: 他写不下啊
Lucia: It won't fit.
Shure:  好
Shure: Okay.
Lucia: 底下还有这种黑纸盒吗
Lucia: Are there any black paper boxes?
Lucia: 730以后再喝别的来
Lucia: Drink something else after 7:30.
Jake: 这样
Jake: Like this.
Lucia: Oh Jesus
Lucia: Oh Jesus.
Katrina:  随便写吧
Katrina: Just write anything.
Shure:  你肯定先避开下一个
Shure: You should definitely avoid the next one.
Tasha: 我觉得这应该写ABCDE
Tasha: I think it should be A, B, C, D, E.
Jake: 对
Jake: Yes.
Jake: 其实你们有些人带着充电宝对吧
Jake: Actually, some of you have power banks, right?
Shure:  是的
Shure: Yes.
Jake: 你自己
Jake: Yourself
Lucia: 哎这样可以少写好些字对
Lucia: Hey, this way we can write fewer words, right?
Shure:  这次都不用尝就看出来了啊
Shure: This time we don't even need to taste it to see, huh?
Katrina:  这个
Katrina: This
Katrina:  最纯净哦
Katrina: The purest one
Shure:  写写写编号对
Shure: Write, write, write the number, right
Lucia: 有的水喝过来没记住那个味怎么办
Lucia: What if you drank some water and can't remember the taste?
Tasha: 尝不出来啊
Tasha: Can't tell the difference
Jake: 多尝几次
Jake: Try a few more times
Jake: 哈哈多尝几次
Jake: Haha, try a few more times
Lucia: 喝完了快
Lucia: Finished it quickly
Katrina:  哈哈哈
Katrina: Hahaha
Jake: 这么这么渴吗
Jake: That thirsty, huh?
Alice: 不是尝尝尝尝
Alice: Not tasting, tasting
Lucia: 刚好补充水分
Lucia: Just replenishing water
Katrina:  交卷
Katrina: Hand in the paper
Katrina:  嗯没有笔吗
Katrina: Hmm, no pen?
Shure:  3都长出来了
Shure: Three has already grown out
Katrina:  整的现在
Katrina: Right now
Jake: 尝出来了
Jake: Can taste it
Katrina:  鉴酒似的
Katrina: Like wine tasting
Lucia: 嗯可以可以
Lucia: Hmm, okay, okay
Lucia: 能写就行
Lucia: As long as you can write
Jake: a b c d f
Jake: 我也想尝尝
Jake: I also want to try
Jake: 一会再尝
Jake: Try later
Jake: 我们一会再尝尝
Jake: We'll try later
Shure:  摸温度哈哈哈好聪明
Shure: Feeling the temperature, haha, so smart
Tasha: 有一瓶好冰啊
Tasha: One bottle is so cold
Jake: 啊哦真的
Jake: Oh really
Alice: 在哪啊不是在哪洗
Alice: Where is it? Not where to wash
Shure:  我估计应该最冰的是他
Shure: I guess the coldest one is this
Shure:  因为他最大
Shure: Because it's the biggest
Shure:  有没有可能
Shure: Could it be
Tasha: 有一瓶好冰啊
Tasha: One bottle is so cold
Alice: 哎答案写在哪啊
Alice: Hey, where do we write the answer?
Katrina:  掰一下给你
Katrina: Break it off for you
Alice: 哦可以可以
Alice: Oh, okay, okay
Alice: 不过我按我的顺序跟他对一下
Alice: But I'll check it against my order
Katrina:  好这样写
Katrina: Okay, write it like this
Alice: 这样可以
Alice: This works.
Alice: 这是啥呀甲
Alice: What is this, Jia?
Katrina:  拿这写也行
Katrina: You can write with this too.
Shure:  f
Shure: f
Shure:  这是f的话题
Shure: This is an f topic.
Shure:  是吗
Shure: Right?
Jake: 我不知道
Jake: I don't know.
Jake: 我乱写
Jake: I'm just scribbling.
Tasha: 有白板笔吗
Tasha: Do we have a whiteboard marker?
Jake: 样题
Jake: Sample question.
Shure:  我绝对不能把我的一包选错
Shure: I absolutely can't choose the wrong one from my pack.
Katrina:  哈哈哈
Katrina: Hahaha.
Katrina:  拭目以待
Katrina: Let's wait and see.
Lucia: 能从这个圆这瓶里再倒出来喝吗
Lucia: Can we pour it out from this bottle and drink it?
Shure:  疯了
Shure: Crazy.
Lucia: 不是
Lucia: No.
Shure:  哦
Shure: Oh.
Lucia: 比较一下吗
Lucia: Just comparing?
Jake: 可以可以
Jake: Sure, sure.
Shure:  没有空杯子
Shure: There are no empty cups.
Lucia: 喝完某一个就好了
Lucia: Finish one and it'll be fine.
Jake: 我们有几位已经整出来了吗感觉
Jake: Have some of us already finished? It seems like it.
Jake: 已经交卷了
Jake: Already submitted?
Katrina:  嗯
Katrina: Yeah.
Jake: 这么牛逼
Jake: That's impressive.
Katrina:  主要是我从来
Katrina: Mainly because I've never...
Jake: 我看一看建浩老师
Jake: Let me check Teacher Jianhao's.
Jake: 来看你的答案
Jake: Let's see your answers.
Katrina:  哈哈哈鹅
Katrina: Hahaha.
Shure:  猜
Shure: Guess.
Katrina:  主要是全不会
Katrina: Mainly because I don't know anything.
Katrina:  就跟那种完全没学过一样
Katrina: It's like I've never studied this at all.
Katrina:  然后哈哈哈
Katrina: And then hahaha.
Jake: 就可以替身交卷
Jake: You could just submit randomly.
Shure:  都选c吧
Shure: Just pick all C's.
Shure:  那不就
Shure: That way...
Katrina:  对啊
Katrina: Yeah.
Katrina:  但是都写怡宝
Katrina: But just write "Yibao" for everything.
Katrina:  总有一个对的
Katrina: One of them has to be right.
Lucia: 好有道理
Lucia: That makes so much sense.
Katrina:  矿泉水
Katrina: Bottled water.
Jake: 对
Jake: Yes.
Lucia: 我打算都写怡宝
Lucia: I plan to write all Evian.
Jake: 哈哈我看看你的怡宝对不对
Jake: Haha, let me see if your Evian is right.
Shure:  是不是对的
Shure: Is it correct?
Jake: 不知道
Jake: Don't know.
Shure:  你看监考是回避我的
Shure: The proctor is avoiding me.
Alice: 给
Alice: Here.
Shure:  嗯
Shure: Hmm.
Jake: 那我还能怎么说呢
Jake: What else can I say?
Jake: 看一看
Jake: Have a look.
Jake: 嗯
Jake: Hmm.
Alice: 怎么了
Alice: What's wrong?
Jake: 没看明白
Jake: Didn't understand it.
Jake: 就是要要倒一下顺序
Jake: We need to reverse the order.
Shure:  我交卷了老师
Shure: I'm handing in my paper, teacher.
Jake: 这样吧你们你们按照这个字母12123456
Jake: Okay, you guys follow this letter sequence 12123456.
Jake: 然后按照字母顺一下
Jake: Then arrange according to the letters.
Jake: 不然我们这个就是像选择题答案一样
Jake: Otherwise, it's like answering multiple choice questions.
Jake: 知道吧我们一会对
Jake: You know, we will match it later.
Jake: 一会我们就会报这个
Jake: Later we will announce it like this.
Jake: EFCD之类的
Jake: Like EFCD or something.
Jake: 这种
Jake: Something like that.
Shure:  没问题
Shure: No problem.
Jake: 来写一下
Jake: Come on, write it down.
Jake: 没没看明白就是
Jake: Didn't understand it, just...
Jake: 交卷
Jake: Hand in the paper.
Alice: 就是一到六
Alice: It's just one to six.
Jake: 答题卡答题卡
Jake: Answer sheet, answer sheet.
Tasha: 44
Tasha: 44.
Katrina:  哎
Katrina: Hey.
Jake: 给收卷
Jake: Collect the papers.
Lucia: 纯净水的矿泉水
Lucia: Pure bottled water.
Jake: 好收卷
Jake: Okay, collect the papers.
Tasha: 啊
Tasha: Ah.
Jake: 收卷
Jake: Collect the papers.
Lucia: 完了
Lucia: It's over.
Lucia: 卷子没写完
Lucia: Didn't finish the paper.
Tasha: 哎
Tasha: Hey.
Katrina:  答题卡没涂
Katrina: Didn't fill out the answer sheet.
Shure:  答题卡没涂
Shure: The answer sheet isn't filled in.
Katrina:  哎
Katrina: Oh
Jake: 不着急不着急
Jake: Don't worry, don't worry.
Jake: 再品一品
Jake: Let's savor it again.
Jake: 说实话农夫山泉那杯我一定选对
Jake: Honestly, I'm sure I got the Nongfu Spring one right.
Katrina:  这有啥区别
Katrina: What's the difference?
Shure:  农夫山泉跟他们那个确实打的不一样
Shure: Nongfu Spring tastes different from theirs.
Shure:  农夫山泉明显不甜
Shure: Nongfu Spring is obviously not sweet.
Shure:  你知道吗
Shure: You know that, right?
Jake: 对
Jake: Right.
Shure:  我还有一个同学
Shure: I have a classmate
Shure:  只要一喝农夫山泉就会拉的
Shure: who always gets diarrhea after drinking Nongfu Spring.
Jake: 对对对对
Jake: Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Katrina:  太那个什么经典说娃哈哈的公子
Katrina: That's so classic, saying the prince of Wahaha.
Shure:  哈哈哈只能喝娃哈哈
Shure: Hahaha, he can only drink Wahaha.
Lucia: 不好意思三五
Lucia: Sorry, three-five.
Tasha: 我就只能喝我就尝出来了娃哈哈的味
Tasha: I can only drink Wahaha, I can taste it.
Lucia: 一个都尝不出来
Lucia: I can't taste any of them.
Katrina:  我去真的
Katrina: Really?
Alice: 这个可以
Alice: This one works.
Katrina:  这一般是便利店里有
Katrina: This is usually found in convenience stores.
Katrina:  什么买哪个便宜卖哪个
Katrina: Just buy whatever's cheaper.
Lucia: 那个可以看看
Lucia: You can take a look at that.
Jake: 答题卡是不是都没写名字呀
Jake: Did everyone forget to write their names on the answer sheets?
Jake: 谁是谁啊
Jake: Who's who?
Jake: 一会互相面面
Jake: Later, we'll check with each other.
Jake: 大家都知道
Jake: Everyone will know.
Jake: 大家都知道对
Jake: Everyone will know, right.
Tasha: 哈哈
Tasha: Haha
Jake: 嗯
Jake: Mm
Katrina:  今天我的生日
Katrina: Today is my birthday.
Shure:  批卷是吧
Shure: Grading papers, right?
Katrina:  要把这
Katrina: Gotta do this...
Jake: 批卷准备
Jake: Prepare for grading.
Jake: 批卷
Jake: Grading.
Lucia: 这些其他能不能多选一个答案啊
Lucia: Can we choose more than one answer for these?
Lucia: 这样保证至少有对的
Lucia: That way, at least one will be right.
Jake: 可以啊可以
Jake: Sure, sure.
Jake: 这个策略是可以的哈哈
Jake: That's a good strategy, haha.
Shure:  快递放在一楼椅子上了
Shure: The package is left on the chair on the first floor.
Jake: 好嘞
Jake: Got it.
Shure:  太有那个高中监考老师那味了
Shure: Feels just like a high school invigilator.
Alice: 哈哈哈
Alice: Hahaha.
Jake: 在晃悠是吧
Jake: Wandering around, right?
Shure:  在晃悠
Shure: Wandering around.
Shure:  然后那个拖鞋还咔咔咔的声你知道吗
Shure: And those slippers making that clack clack sound, you know?
Jake: 然后没事看一看你们的答案
Jake: And then casually glancing at your answers.
Shure:  对
Shure: Yeah.
Katrina:  然后咂一声
Katrina: And then a clicking sound.
Katrina:  嗯然后这个同学就慌
Katrina: Yeah, and the student gets nervous.
Shure:  然后在他旁边叹口气唉唉
Shure: And then sighing next to him, like "sigh, sigh".
Alice: 唉
Alice: Sigh.
Jake: 再指指点点
Jake: Then pointing around.
Jake: 这题写错了
Jake: "This question is wrong."
Tasha: 点 就是不说话
Tasha: Points, but doesn't say anything.
Jake: 帮2分呵呵
Jake: "Minus 2 points, haha."
Alice: 也不当就这样
Alice: Not even that, just like that.
Alice: 就指点一下
Alice: Just pointing.
Lucia: 然后就这样吧
Lucia: And that's it.
Jake: 好的互相p吧
Jake: Okay, let's peer review.
Jake: 我们也不想看
Jake: We don't even want to check.
Shure:  互相p照
Shure: Peer review.
Shure:  我天
Shure: Oh my.
Katrina:  我天呐天呐天呐
Katrina: Oh my gosh, oh my gosh.
Shure:  真的是给外国人一些
Shure: Really giving some to foreigners.
Jake: 对
Jake: Yeah.
Shure:  这是我自个的
Shure: This is my own.
Katrina:  这这不是我的吗
Katrina: Isn't this mine?
Jake: 这是
Jake: It is.
Lucia: 啊写了写了
Lucia: Ah, wrote it down.
Shure:  那个我也写这个啊
Shure: I wrote this too.
Lucia: 这我自己认
Lucia: I recognize this.
Tasha: 这什么意思啊
Tasha: What does this mean?
Tasha: 看不懂
Tasha: Can't understand.
Katrina:  老铁
Katrina: Buddy.
Katrina:  你自由我扯
Katrina: You pull, I tug.
Tasha: 三是a是吧
Tasha: Three is A, right?
Jake: 是谁的呀
Jake: Whose is this?
Jake: 真的是你的
Jake: Really yours?
Katrina:  是我的呀
Katrina: It's mine.
Tasha: 那他这个e写的是啥呀
Tasha: What did he write for "e"?
Lucia: 那是我的哦
Lucia: That's mine.
Tasha: 一是c好行
Tasha: One is "c", alright.
Jake: 好好来
Jake: Alright, let's go.
Alice: 公布答案
Alice: Announce the answers.
Jake: 公布答案
Jake: Announce the answers.
Jake: 一第一个是
Jake: Okay, the first one is...
Katrina:  我倒是写了
Katrina: I did write it down.
Alice: 哎呀
Alice: Oh no.
Jake: 一个是啥呀
Jake: What is the first one?
Alice: 第一个是啥
Alice: What is the first one?
Jake: 第一个是a
Jake: The first one is "a".
Jake: 哈哈哈啊
Jake: Hahaha.
Shure:  啊
Shure: Ah.
Jake: 第一个是农夫山泉
Jake: The first one is Nongfu Spring.
Jake: 第二个是啥
Jake: What's the second one?
Jake: 第二个是苏打水d嗯
Jake: The second one is soda water, "d", yeah.
Shure:  这倒是能尝出来嗯
Shure: You can definitely taste that, yeah.
Jake: 第三个是百岁山
Jake: The third one is Baisui Mountain.
Katrina:  二是b第三是c
Katrina: Two is "b", and three is "c".
Jake: c第四个是e
Jake: "C", the fourth one is "e".
Jake: 这个都这不能不对了
Jake: This can't be wrong.
Jake: 第五个是娃哈哈
Jake: The fifth one is Wahaha.
Jake: 是b
Jake: It's "b".
Shure:  你还给人家改
Shure: You're even changing others' answers.
Shure:  哈哈哈
Shure: Hahaha.
Katrina:  不小心就是
Katrina: It was an accident.
Lucia: 哎呀这手控制不住
Lucia: Oh no, I can't control my hand.
Katrina:  ABC
Katrina: ABC.
Jake: 我是不是
Jake: Am I...
Jake: 我是不是写错了
Jake: Did I write it wrong?
Jake: 哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha.
Alice: 第六个是啥呀
Alice: What's the sixth one?
Katrina:  FS
Katrina: FS.
Jake: 第六个是
Jake: The sixth one is...
Jake: 第六个是娃哈哈
Jake: The sixth one is Wahaha.
Lucia: 第六个是娃
Lucia: The sixth one is Wahaha.
Jake: 没有第五个是怡宝
Jake: No, the fifth one is Yibao.
Jake: 第五个是怡宝
Jake: The fifth one is Yibao.
Jake: 给你们一些surprise
Jake: Giving you guys a surprise.
Shure:  第五是怡宝
Shure: Fifth is Yi Bao.
Lucia: 所以第五个是F
Lucia: So the fifth one is F.
Jake: 第五是一对
Jake: Fifth is a pair.
Jake: 第五是f
Jake: Fifth is F.
Lucia: 第六个是b
Lucia: The sixth one is B.
Jake: 对
Jake: Right.
Lucia: 好吧我给人家写标上答案写错了
Lucia: Okay, I wrote the wrong answer on the label.
Katrina:  哎随便批吧
Katrina: Eh, just grade it casually.
Shure:  你就只错了两个
Shure: You only got two wrong.
Katrina:  真的吗纯瞎写
Katrina: Really? I just guessed randomly.
Katrina:  2分钟写完
Katrina: Finished in 2 minutes.
Shure:  农夫山泉和娃哈哈
Shure: Nongfu Spring and Wahaha.
Shure:  顺序反了
Shure: The order is reversed.
Shure:  剩下都是对的
Shure: The rest are correct.
Lucia: 这是
Lucia: This is...
Jake: 几分啊
Jake: How many points?
Jake: 大家都几分啊
Jake: How many points did everyone get?
Jake: 来
Jake: Come on.
Tasha: 这是谁的
Tasha: Whose is this?
Shure:  这是我的
Shure: This is mine.
Jake: 好这个是我们
Jake: Okay, this is us.
Jake: 从我们从宇轩的乌鸦的考卷开始是吧
Jake: Starting from Yuxuan's crow's test paper, right?
Lucia: 哎
Lucia: Hey.
Katrina:  3分
Katrina: 3 points.
Lucia: 刚把这些都交回去了
Lucia: Just handed all these back.
Shure:  哇哈乌鸦3分
Shure: Wow, crow got 3 points.
Katrina:  f b这是b是对的
Katrina: F, B, this B is correct.
Katrina:  对不起批卷老师有点那个哦
Katrina: Sorry, the grading teacher made a mistake.
Tasha: 4分天呐
Tasha: 4 points, oh my God.
Jake: 来大家看看有没有改错
Jake: Come on, everyone check if there are mistakes.
Jake: 呵呵呵太典了
Jake: Haha, so classic.
Katrina:  批卷老师批错了
Katrina: The grading teacher made a mistake.
Katrina:  然后去办公室找批卷老师要
Katrina: Then went to the office to find the grading teacher.
Jake: 乌鸦得了4分
Jake: The crow got 4 points.
Katrina:  天呐
Katrina: Oh my God.
Jake: 修硕几分啊
Jake: Shure, how many points?
Jake: 你也是4分
Jake: You also got 4 points.
Shure:  但是我把怡宝选对了
Shure: But I got Yi Bao right.
Jake: 好的
Jake: Okay.
Jake: 你选几分
Jake: What score did you choose?
Katrina:  我也是4分
Katrina: I chose 4 as well.
Jake: 都是4分
Jake: All 4s.
Shure:  呀
Shure: Wow.
Alice: 3
Alice: 3.
Shure:  最后一个交卷
Shure: Last one to hand in.
Shure:  和第一个交卷的人答案是得分
Shure: Has the same score as the first one to submit.
Shure:  这个得分一样
Shure: This score is the same.
Jake: 几分
Jake: What’s the score?
Katrina:  2分
Katrina: 2 points.
Jake: 2分
Jake: 2 points.
Jake: 你为什么得2分
Jake: Why did you get 2 points?
Tasha: 哈哈哈
Tasha: Hahaha.
Jake: OK
Jake: OK.
Jake: 好这是3分
Jake: Alright, this is 3 points.
Jake: 2分3分一排4分
Jake: 2 points, 3 points, all in a row, 4 points.
Jake: 那决胜一下
Jake: Let’s decide the winner.
Katrina:  好石头剪刀布
Katrina: Alright, rock-paper-scissors.
Katrina:  石头剪刀
Katrina: Rock-paper.
Tasha: 他们仨
Tasha: The three of them.
Shure:  他仨
Shure: Those three.
Jake: 怎么决胜呢
Jake: How do we decide the winner?
Katrina:  石头剪刀布
Katrina: Rock-paper-scissors.
Jake: 你们你们喝出吧
Jake: You guys drink and figure it out.
Jake: 你们喝出来这这这
Jake: You guys drink and figure out the taste of these.
Jake: 3瓶矿泉4瓶矿泉水的味了吗
Jake: Can you taste the difference in these 3 bottles of mineral water and 4 bottles of purified water?
Lucia: 两瓶纯净水两个矿泉水
Lucia: Two bottles of purified water and two bottles of mineral water.
Lucia: 只能看别的
Lucia: Just look at others.
Lucia: 大概
Lucia: About right.
Katrina:  这这位不是专业嘛
Katrina: Isn’t this one an expert?
Katrina:  他说他
Katrina: He said he...
Shure:  我怡宝是能喝
Shure: I can drink Yibao.
Alice: 怡宝比较甜
Alice: Yibao is sweeter.
Shure:  对怡宝真的是这里面最甜的
Shure: Yeah, Yibao really is the sweetest among these.
Alice: 然后农夫山泉有一点辣嗓子
Alice: And Nongfu Spring kind of irritates the throat.
Tasha: 啊
Tasha: Ah.
Alice: 有点涩然后他没有味
Alice: It's a bit astringent and has no taste.
Alice: 然后他有一点点那种
Alice: And it has a bit of that...
Shure:  好像
Shure: Seems like...
Shure:  好像只有农夫山泉是偏碱性的
Shure: Seems like only Nongfu Spring is slightly alkaline.
Alice: 就农夫山泉不太好喝
Alice: I don't think Nongfu Spring tastes that good.
Shure:  我也觉得
Shure: I think so too.
Katrina:  哦我喝出来了
Katrina: Oh, I can taste it now.
Alice: 怡宝比较甜
Alice: Yibao is sweeter.
Jake: 好那这样吧我们
Jake: Alright, how about this, we...
Jake: 我来看一下
Jake: Let me take a look.
Katrina:  嗯农夫山泉是几啊
Katrina: Hmm, what's the number for Nongfu Spring?
Shure:  农夫山泉
Shure: Nongfu Spring.
Shure:  农夫山泉是一
Shure: Nongfu Spring is number one.
Jake: 好这样吧
Jake: Alright, how about this.
Jake: 我们来看一下各位手机的电量
Jake: Let's check everyone's phone battery levels.
Jake: 然后决定这个
Jake: And then decide the...
Jake: 最后的赢家
Jake: Final winner.
Tasha: 我已经失败了
Tasha: I've already lost.
Shure:  我也是百分之18
Shure: Me too, I'm at 18%.
Katrina:  50
Katrina: 50.
Lucia: 96
Lucia: 96.
Shure:  哇
Shure: Wow.
Jake: 哇
Jake: Wow.
Lucia: 昨天晚上刚充的电
Lucia: I charged it last night.
Lucia: 早上就拔下来
Lucia: Unplugged it this morning.
Jake: 恭喜96号玩家
Jake: Congratulations to player 96.
Katrina:  晚上也充了玩
Katrina: I also charged mine last night.
Katrina:  玩到了50
Katrina: Played it down to 50.
Tasha: 没关系
Tasha: It's okay.
Jake: 好的那我们就按照这样的顺序
Jake: Alright, so we'll follow this order.
Jake: 96
Jake: 96.
Alice: 96
Alice: 96.
Jake: 呃 96
Jake: Uh, 96.
Jake: 先选礼物对吧
Jake: Picks the gift first, right?
Jake: 一会我们会把每个人的礼物给拿上来
Jake: We'll bring up everyone's gifts in a bit.
Jake: 介绍介绍
Jake: And introduce them.
Jake: 嗯
Jake: Hmm.
Shure:  嗯我们要自己拿一下是吗
Shure: Hmm, do we need to bring them ourselves?
Jake: 对你们自己拿上来
Jake: Yes, you bring them up yourselves.
Jake: 然后我们把披萨也拿上来
Jake: And we'll bring up the pizza too.
Jake: 你们就边吃边聊吧好吧
Jake: You guys can chat while eating, okay?
Jake: 然后这个水就当边吃披萨边喝就好了
Jake: And you can drink this water while eating the pizza.
Katrina:  好这是我的
Katrina: Okay, this is mine.
Jake: 这是你们的饮品
Jake: These are your drinks.
Katrina:  一天8杯水
Katrina: Eight glasses of water a day.
Lucia: 哈哈哈一天8杯水
Lucia: Hahaha, eight glasses of water a day.
Lucia: 这才6杯
Lucia: This is only six glasses.
Lucia: 还差两杯
Lucia: Still two more to go.
Jake: 大家把礼物拿上来吧
Jake: Everyone, bring the gifts up.
Jake: 好吧一天可是一杯也没喝呀
Jake: Well, you haven't had even one glass today.
Katrina:  今天可是一杯也没喝呀
Katrina: Yeah, not even one glass today.
Lucia: 我看看我给里面装东西了吧
Lucia: Let me see if I put anything inside.
Lucia: 别光带了个盒就搞笑了
Lucia: Don't just bring a box, that'll be funny.
Shure:  没事客气了你
Shure: No worries, you're being too polite.
Alice: 就出去倒点
Alice: Just pour some out.
Shure:  我闻到有榴莲的披萨了
Shure: I smell durian pizza.
Jake: 我们把这个
Jake: Let's take this...
Tasha: 不是这个
Tasha: Not this one.
Jake: 啊
Jake: Ah.
Tasha: 没事不是
Tasha: It's okay, not this one.
Jake: 哪个
Jake: Which one then?
Lucia: 这水把它掺一块
Lucia: Mix this water together.
Lucia: 然后
Lucia: Then...
Tasha: 卖苏打水和元气森林
Tasha: Sell soda water and Genki Forest drinks.
Lucia: 呃和元气森林已经喝完了
Lucia: Uh, we've already finished the Genki Forest drinks.
Lucia: 哈哈
Lucia: Haha.
Tasha: 啊
Tasha: Ah.
Lucia: 对
Lucia: Yes.
Lucia: 这样我能节约点空间
Lucia: This way I can save some space.
Lucia: 给他两杯合一杯
Lucia: Combine two glasses into one.
Katrina:  磕
Katrina: Knock.
Jake: 对都喝吧都
Jake: Yes, everyone drink up.
Jake: 然后这个披萨大家一起摆一摆
Jake: And then let's arrange the pizza together.
Alice: 哎不得先交换吗
Alice: Oh, don't we have to exchange first?
Alice: 先交换
Alice: Exchange first.
Jake: 边吃边
Jake: Eat and...
Jake: 边吃边聊
Jake: Eat and chat.
Lucia: 本餐厅招募信息如下
Lucia: Here is the recruitment information for our restaurant.
Jake: pizza Tuesday pizza first day
Jake: Pizza Tuesday, pizza first day.
Tasha: 榴莲的在这个箱子里
Tasha: The durian one is in this box.
Tasha: 啊哎
Tasha: Ah, hey.
Lucia: 怎么这么多啊
Lucia: Why are there so many?
Lucia: 还有小食是吗
Lucia: Are there snacks too?
Katrina:  鸡哥
Katrina: Chicken guy.
Lucia: 这是小龙虾味
Lucia: This is crayfish flavor.
Katrina:  我好想吃小龙虾
Katrina: I really want to eat crayfish.
Lucia: 那可以把小龙虾摆的靠那边一点
Lucia: Then we can place the crayfish a bit closer to that side.
Lucia: 我没看错吧
Lucia: Am I seeing this right?
Lucia: 上面写的好像是小龙虾
Lucia: It seems like it says crayfish on it.
Tasha: 这个和这个一样
Tasha: This one is the same as this one.
Tasha: 放到这哎
Tasha: Put it here.
Jake: 这个是一样的吗
Jake: Are these the same?
Tasha: 嗯
Tasha: Yeah.
Lucia: 照烧牛肉
Lucia: Teriyaki beef.
Lucia: 哦我以前很喜欢吃这个味
Lucia: Oh, I used to love this flavor.